документ опублікувала в це ж на ті
міфи я кияк поважають у брюсселі москва
ширше раз побачу чифранів спк зони
вільній торгівлі між ес то Україною та
не старший росія може ви нас троє нього
порядку заміни ти мити не провалу вже в
тсн дбс консультації меншим пішла на 8
ноти
брюссель з 3g че росія та здоров'я
провала зона вільно та торгівля синді
коли в односторонньому порядку зменшуючи
преференції спочатку молдову а потім
україн звіт перевищить їм це на імпорт
продукції судні іскра inspire товар
вид-во моя росія просто консультації в
рамках снг а також довести рахунок зростання не
імпорту з'їзд через Україну можна на
skoda цим цьому союзу міф інший
євросоюз вимагаєш спідницю вся продукція до
продаєте в Україні
вид у ідола технічних стандартів ес
цілий тягаючи російські товари з
українського ринку Україна вже пройшла на
європейські стандарти у 24 категоріях 27
і виду російських підприємств не знайдеш
також одна з кишені проблем з експортом
продукції в Україні вкажіть брюсселі
при тему виразку то ви продовжите
паразитний період за диким та категоріям
це варив легше росії доведено загальної
сьогодні такий вчинок міф третій є
хоче мусати русі змінить і мити
неправильного вадим про зону вільну
торгівлі СНГ росія поважають нинішній
провалу в зоні вільної торгівлі СНГ
Майкл і США рекомендаційний характер
Криму дозволяють Україні пустку
відіграюся та імпортного не з'їсть товару
як свою владу не безсмертних зборі
єврокомісія за пропливала чоловічі
зради ти провела в торговому usb
снд
легше на думку Росії он і сперечатися
проблеми коли 16 років уперед і укладу та
угоду правильно торги плюс 3 і державою
міф 4 є чоловік і росію за проводить і
європейські норми фітосанітарного
контролю у брюсселі заповнюють є
нікулін із чоловік його в росію за провід
це європейські стандарти у this story
єврокомісія лише ізопропанолу Москви
продовжує і двосторонні консультації
рахунку санітарних стандартів
міф п'ятий російсько
проведення пари 7 періоду максимум на
десять років в Україні секторах торгівлі
але і проблеми і уе борються на багатий
уроки в позику а лапу в данину з нічної
частина стіни біля води про зону вільну і
тури в ліс україну тієї ж години брецелі
сумнівається ще c допомогло держбюджету
експорт російських товарів до України
міф шостий росія вимагатиме докладних
даних про ціни їм це на шкіру
транзакцію мішеооста україну а брюссель
по ви на треба вати Москві таку
інформацію повіт за ціну
дозволити Москві від ремонту і достовірну
інформацію про пригоди товарі столітті
Росія буду імпортувати ВАТ з України про
крим товари супу вирішити законом йосики
гарантувати confident синій з ділової
інформації